Let's also take a look at how
this can affect the results
on a simple set of data using age and
income as the two variables that
we could use to build out a model.
To start with, we're going to create
a scatter plot that compares the age and
income in each survey response for
all the data without eliminating
any of the observations.
We can reuse the workflow
we created in the quiz.
We'll drag a scatter plot
tool onto the canvas and
configure it by setting age as the x
field and income as the y field.
Click on the plot elements tab and
deselect the smooth line option
as we don't need any smoothing.
We just want the original
regression line.
Attach a browse tool and then run
the workflow to create the scatter plot.
When we look at the result, we can see
a scatter plot that compares age and
income in each survey response for
all the data without eliminating
any of the observations.
Without getting into too much
detail of the scatter plot itself,
we can see the income tends
to trend up as age increases.
We'll run the work flow again with the
second scatter plot added after the data
set where we removed all the records
that had a null in any one of
the fields.
We can see that the new scatter plot
has a relationship between age and
income that's fairly flat.
This could obviously make a significant
difference in the model you build and
give inaccurate results.
Let's test our knowledge of scatter
plots and missing data with a quiz